okay hopefully this felt a bit more
familiar and happy so now we're just
dealing with geometrical applications of
calculus stationary points turn your
points all that jazz okay have a look at
this
I hope that my solution in this case
speaks for itself and there are no weird
mystery curveballs you know what am i
doing what am i doing second derivative
I'm looking for a change in concavity
I've found two possible places where it
might happen which is why I say they may
occur but of course we know that the
second derivative being zero is no
guarantee so that's why I have to test
okay and you can see one of the possible
points of inflection isn't one so
there's no change in the sign of the
second derivative whereas the other one
is so this one's good and this one's are
done okay makes sense the question says
find the singular exponent of the point
inflection so all you need is x equals
three you don't even need to find
coordinates so you're welcome okay Part
B Part B is something of a classic
question in Max being there's only so
many varieties of things that we want to
maximize or minimize and this is one of
the this is one of the classic ones so
you've got all of the dimensions there
they give you a long preamble that tells
you what exactly they're doing with this
cylinder and with this rectangular beam
but you have to you can dive in fairly
rapidly in fact if you if you recognize
this thing show that s which is the
strength of the beam is given by that
equation okay now just look on the
question paper before we look at my
answer look at the question paper
immediately before part one there's us
there's already an equation which has an
estimate right it says s equals K D
square W what are we doing from that
equation to this one where I'm supposed
to show what's the difference yeah
there's you do a substitution to
eliminate D right now the reason we do
this is simple I want to differentiate
so I want an equation with one variable
not - there's a K in there but why don't
I mind about the K it's a it's a
constant it's a pro normal but it's not
of variables you don't need to worry
about it okay so all you need to do is
throw in some Pythagoras good ole
Pythagoras that way you can substitute
out d squared so that part Falls
fairly happily part two it's four marks
why is it so many marks because there's
not to do right you've got to
differentiate you can see my derivative
there
I chose before I even went through I
already chose to do a second derivative
why because it's easy to differentiate I
know I'm gonna have to test see it says
justify your answer so I'm gonna need to
show that this is a maximum fitara
question yep yep yep okay so if the
Neuros question is about the numbers
yeah I'm gonna put to the rest of you
what is this question about what is this
question trying to assess and there's
many right answers tell me it's tell me
something it's asking for you to assess
can you differentiate okay what else is
it looking for can you test for
concavity or in the neighborhood to know
what kind of a stationary point you
found can you find a stationary point
all right can you then interpret etc now
can we do all of those is there another
one you're thinking of you're cheeky can
you divide two to five by three I think
is not one of the things that this
question is about now that said like you
have a calculator man come on
right and yeah it's I can virtually
guarantee if everything else is fine you
get your four marks just um divided by
three next time okay you can see I've
done my test I use the second derivative
please note just look closely in here
that K that K is a constant but you
can't just ignore it right so I found my
second derivative I substituted in the
value of W that I found right but you
can't just oh it's not there right it is
there but it's positive the question
told you so right so Beeman it's
positive it doesn't change the sign of
this whole product in here right
negative times positive times positive
that'll give you a negative concave down
I'm happy okay
but that
so that's a thing right I rather than
thinner is division by three that thing
there if you're lucky you might get away
with not putting that down but
mathematically that's kind of important
because if K's not greater than zero
then you have to worry about that right
so that's a that's a minor point but I
still think it's important the question
asks for dimensions not just W so that's
why you can see I go through this
process I find the depth and then off I
go okay I couldn't actually complete the
last part of this question because I had
to lend my calculator there's someone
and so I couldn't do this part but you
should you should be able to find the
numbers you can see that from here I've
got the maximum strength that we found
or at least we thought we found and then
down here is the strength if it's a
square beam yeah and presumably I guess
I would divide if I could be bothered to
do that without a calculator and I would
find the 8% difference
okay all right now for Part C I'm just
looking at the time I'm just gonna show
you the last part I'm sorry the first
part of the last part you have to
eliminate the parameter now we're
generally pretty good at eliminating
parameters but maybe you looked at that
equation and you did a rustle and you're
like you actually did this one good on
your wrestle maybe you're like I don't
even want to get started cuz I don't
even know where to go
okay well being that they give you the
Cartesian equation that's a big red flag
for you to say hey use this right I want
you to know where you're going so being
that I know I'm going to end up with y
equals and then look at that a Cartesian
that big awful rational function mess I
can find what X plus 1 is I've been told
what X is and I can find what X minus 1
is that's what I do here can you see
I've I found what X plus 1 is and I just
simplified that out I found what X minus
1 is and I simplify that out and then I
just throw them in to what they've told
me right like I can work with this thing
and then it should all come out in the
wash it looks terrible but it does sure
enough come out in the wash ok
so you don't need to guess as to how do
what what way do I twist these things to
combine them if they give you a clue use
the clue ok